let's bring in uh gary vaynerchuk the uh
entrepreneurial star of vayner media the
ceo
and uh why the resurgence in collecting
sports cards
there's multiple reasons one 45 year
olds
uh you know the great year of sports
cards in the last three four decades was
that 80
1985 to 1993 range where it was complete
you know chaos and everybody was into it
and that
guy and so and obviously some women as
well but that guy
predominantly is now 45 to 50
and has children that are now eight and
nine
and just like in the toy industry and
other businesses you see reboots every
30 years
you're seeing that with sports that's
one two gambling
the explosion of gambling in the last
decade what gamblers are realizing
instead of daily fantasy and just
betting on games that they're able to
make more money being right about jason
tatum
or tyler hero or you know giannis
than even betting on those teams or
those variables so that's been a huge
factor and then
three you've got the sneaker flipper
kids
if you know for people that are
listening if you've got kids that have
been doing this over the last 10 years
but the flipping
of premium sneakers buying and selling
so the entrepreneurial element there
that's happening
and then for youtube there's the
explosion of people opening up
packs on the internet and that being
entertainment
this what's called pack breaking so
those are four
major uh things converging at the same
time
that has really led to and then social
media overlay like people sharing
their zion pull or their great kobe
collection
uh you just have some a lot of
ingredients stand for why this is
happening now
what is hot right now basketball
you know basketball is uncomfortably hot
both vintage and
modern i think a lot of people will lose
money and i'm going to say this
again clearly people will lose money on
modern because they're going to
bet on a young player let's use tyler
hero because it's
relevant who looks all the part but so
so did derrick rose i mean derek rose
looked more the part and injuries are
variable and if you spent a hundred
thousand dollars investing in derrick
rose years ago it would have looked
good but you would have got caught like
you would have got caught on bo jackson
and grant hill and others
um but young basketball modern
basketball is very hot
vintage basketball has completely
exploded dr j
rookie cards in a 8 out of 10 grade
as you get more into the world you know
that there's companies now that you send
it to and they grade it
psa bgs sgc these are the companies that
grade cards
a dr j psa eight was eight hundred
dollars
a year ago and now is an eight thousand
dollar card
you know that's a ten times explosion
are these the new stocks i mean would
you rather invest in cards or stocks
i would rather invest in cards but i
need everybody to hear this
why i'd like to diversify from the
stocks that i own
um when you're dealing you know times
like this
uncertainty potential recession after
the covid thing
you know like non-stock market assets
alternative assets tend to go down but
not as much with upside
three it makes me happy so i would
rather own
you know a will chamberlain two hundred
thousand dollar
piece of art than an actual piece of art
like i don't want that i don't want a
warhol i don't want
you know jackson pollock i want the
greatest sports cards because of my
interests because growing up watching
you every single day like that was my
life
uh and because of the rarity i i think
that
the top five percent of sports cards the
most rare stuff
is about to go through its contemporary
art phase that we saw in the late 60s
70s and 80s with the
before mentioned warhol and pollock so i
just think michael jordan rookies
in a perfect 10 there's only 313 of them
dan
they were 25 30 000 about 18 months ago
they're
hovering around a hundred thousand it is
my professional
investor businessman belief that that's
a half a million dollar card in 10 years
that's a good return michael jordan
his name you know when you invest in
real estate neighborhoods covid
there's pretty much nothing that can
happen at this point with michael jordan
outside of i don't want to go there but
like outside of an o.j
simpson like be like you're talking
about the rarest of rare thing that can
do
anything to diminish his demand and the
supply is non-existent
and the demand overall for this art is
exploding and i think you're going to
see those things play out
what's your most valuable card i bought
a psa 9 jackie robinson
1948 leaf rookie card with another
friend we split it
how much we spent hundreds and hundreds
of thousands of dollars each and i
believe the card now based
on what's happened in the market last
two years could be pushing over a
million dollars in value because there's
only
nine of them and i think when you think
about what jackie robinson represents
and where america is in this life cycle
it's always been an under-priced card
compared to honest wagner and babe ruth
and ty cobb and
i think we're starting to feel the
demand really explode for it
but i have a bunch of cards at home that
are still in the packs
and it's from the 90s yeah you
worthless and i do too
because because knowing your career and
being such an admirer
and this is for everyone who's listening
this was what was happening
in the 80s and 90s there was this gold
rush
and everyone said buy these things store
them because what was happening the
things from the 50s and 60s the mantels
the errands the clementes were the
problem was
people didn't understand how much supply
tops was making
millions in cards and by the way
matt nooks and eric so you know eric
davis and
wally joyner and you know mike greenwell
and ellis burks
did not become ty cobb and mike
greenwell
which then made those cards vulnerable
and that's why i
tell a lot of kids and if you're a
parent of a kid or a kid listening right
now
listen i'm very excited about tyler hero
too and i'm
super can't wait to watch you know jason
tatum and
jaylen brown develop and donovan
mitchell and i'm super excited but
remember this unless you're a top 100
icon
your cards are not going to be worth as
much as you think 25 30 years around
kevin garnett and duncan and ray allen
are less
expensive than some of the rookies now
because everyone's
projecting what john murant and you know
and r.j barrett and zion are gonna do
versus understanding who those players
were
and that's why i keep saying dan over
and over vintage vintage vintage vintage
that's where the action is he's uh gary
vaynerchuk he's the ceo of vaynermedia
but uh most known as garyvee on social
media a
serial entrepreneur five-time new york
times best-selling author and host of
tea with gary vee every day helping
entrepreneurs build and grow their
businesses during the pandemic
what happens if a card is autographed
what does that do to the value
when it comes in the current packs over
the last 15 years the card companies
have done autographs in packs
that's good if it's done by hand the way
that you and i grew up
they tend to be lower in value than
actually the cards so
in that general area sometimes a little
bit more depending on who's signing
my son collected pokemon cards
i have i have the he has
them in uh plastic and i actually my
wife got him for me last night because
she knew i was gonna talk to you today
and i don't know the value of that but
he am i gonna be rich gary
well dan you're rich so i don't know if
you know that richer
richer yes if it's the right
shadowless first edition charizard
hollow
like anything i have a couple of those
okay well that gets
damn we're gonna have to talk offline
here like i really need to know if you
have the one like you have to text me a
picture because
because a perfect 10 charizard hollow
shadowless first edition is over a
hundred thousand dollars
let's go uh shop in here yeah i mean
here's what i would say though knowing
who listens to this incredible show
if you love sports a lot of you have
decided to
gamble because it makes sports that you
naturally don't have fandom into
far more interesting what i know about
gambling is
it can be bad and what i know about
sports cards is
you can get the same thrill i mean i
watched
that mavericks clippers series like
crazy because
when i first got back in two years ago i
decided through the first half of his
career that luca
donach was going to be something really
special he affirmed that this year and
especially in the playoffs
so i'm sitting on a massive amounts of
luca rookies that i paid 35
for that were at 2 000 at the height of
that run now they're down to twelve
thirteen hundred seasons over but
as you can imagine luca eliminating the
clippers would have done some real
damage and probably would have pushed it
to three thousand
the juices were going that was a
clippers mavs game that i wouldn't watch
a year ago so so for everybody who's
listening if you know
a lot of us love to debate sports and we
all play monday morning quarterback for
example
i'm very glad that i wasn't making
content about my points of view on
patrick mahomes
coming out of college i would have been
uncomfortably historically incorrect
i didn't see it and he's and he's got
all the pieces in place to be all time
scary
it's great to talk to you gary thank you
for sharing and i hope to cross paths
with you again soon
anytime and by the way dan please tell
me something that can give me
some optimism on my new york jet season
can you give me something like
i am in a real funk there's only 15
games left gary
what about bechten is a surefire hall of
famer i mean he looks incredible
13 seconds into his career have you
bought any of his rookie cards
i haven't because anthony munoz rookie
cards are like six dollars
oh offensive linemen are not going to
change
thank you by the way beckton's injured
he's not playing this weekend
not true i'm too on top of my stuff
paulie is bechten playing this
mclovin is becton playing just came
across the wire that mackay beckton
pulled out of practice with an injury no
but you don't know how severe it is
garyvee look it up i believe you thought
i am
i am literally literally dead i just
died
i'm dead oh my god it's true and i do it
sorry to break the news to you gare
i am literally dead when i tell you
that i am in such a catonic state of
like holding on to
well at least we have jonathan ogden for
this to be live
right now yeah i mean
all right dan we'll talk soon keep your
head up
i cannot believe that just happened